se un viaggiatore nel tempo potesse
balzare con agilità attraverso i secoli
probabilmente si stenterebbe riconoscere
molte delle tecnologie che hanno
impresso un profondo cambiamento negli
ambiti della società contemporanea nella
quale viviamo e che conosciamo
pensiamo ad esempio all'ambito medico
oppure all'azienda ancora al settore dei
mezzi di trasporto bene
tutti tranne uno qua ha cambiato
soltanto il colore la scuola la scuola è
riuscita nel corso dei secoli a
mantenere invariati immutate alcune
delle sue caratteristiche ma perché la
scuola dovrebbe cambiare è proprio
necessario o è una questione di moda beh
se le immagini parlano chiaro ad
ammonirci con maggiore incisività sono
sicuramente i dati i dati che
fotografano un forte scollamento della
scuola rispetto alle sfide alle
competenze richieste dalla società della
conoscenza nella quale viviamo
e questa guardate non è un'emergenza
avvertita soltanto a livello nazionale
ma direi a livello europeo a livello
mondiale
ce lo dicono i dati delle relazioni
internazionali
l'ocse in ambito nazionale sulla dice
l'istat i dati sull'abbandono prematuro
precoce sono ancora troppo alti ci
attestiamo sul 17 per cento rispetto
all'obiettivo europeo che ci siamo dati
del 10 per cento
beh ma l'analisi dei problemi potrebbe
andare molto per le lunghe ci potrebbe
portar via molto tempo
in realtà sono qua oggi con voi da voi
per parlare di scuole parlarne in chiave
propositiva
vorrei infatti condividere con voi le
esperienze di alcune scuole che hanno
deciso di uscire dalla zona di comfort
uno spazio sicuramente comodo per
spostarsi invece in un rogo scomodo sì
decisamente scomodo dove le parole
innovazione e cambiamento non incutono
timore cambiamento change è questo
l'argomento che ci vede qui riuniti oggi
bene queste scuole di cui vi parlerò a
breve
hanno iniziato a scrivere
quotidianamente la loro piccola grande
storia di ordinaria innovazioni ma
iniziamo a conoscerle per esempio in
questa immagine
ci sono dei ragazzi che al cambio
dell'ora devono rispettare un senso di
marcia ma cosa significa come mai
e qua vediamo dei ragazzi seduti in
maniera disordinata scomposta certamente
non li vediamo seduti nei banchi in file
allineati come siamo abituati a
conoscerli ancora qua ci sono due
ragazzi che stanno tenendo una lezione
teatro lg hanno il possesso proprio il
protagonismo totale della lezione non
vediamo l'insegnante è questo che cos'è
questa è un orario scolastico
beh chi ha deciso che le scienze si
fanno per esempio tutti i lunedì e
mercoledì dalle 9 alle 10
e qui ancora che cosa sta succedendo i
ragazzi non prendono appunti si stanno
distraendo cosa succede beh queste
immagini provengono da alcune delle
scuole con le quali stiamo lavorando che
sono scuole che hanno accettato di
giocarsi tutto hanno accettato di
rispondere alle sfide della società
della conoscenza e sono partiti proprio
da quello che avevano dalle cose
semplici hanno iniziato a fare leva sui
meccanismi dell'autonomia scolastica che
in vigore da 16 anni ma ancora sono
troppo poco sfruttati e hanno sognato
una scuola hanno sognato la scuola come
qualcuno di quegli ambienti che il
nostro viaggiatore del tempo non
riconoscerebbe cioè quegli ambienti che
sono cambiati profondamente hanno
cambiato profondamente il paradigma che
le contraddistingue sotto l'impulso
dell'innovazione sono scuole
d'avanguardia ma lasciate che torni un
attimo indietro per raccontarvi meglio
queste immagini che adesso vi ho
mostrato così soltanto in chiave
provocatoria torniamo indietro alla
prima ci sono delle scuole nelle quali i
ragazzi a cambio dell'ora si alzano
cambiano la stanza mentre il docente
resta lì e devono rispettare un senso di
marcia perché le scuole spesso hanno
moltissimi studenti ma come mai perché
in queste scuole l'ambiente lo spazio
fisico non è avvertito come uno spazio
asettico
ma come un luogo che deve essere
caratterizzata
deve essere proprio della materia
oggetto di insegnamento un luogo che
deve essere personale non soltanto
guardate delle discipline di indirizzo o
quelle tecniche ma anche proprio delle
discipline di base quindi al cambio
dell'ora ragazzi si spostano si muovono
il docente resto nella stanza resta
nell'aula pronta ad allestire il setting
l'ambiente fisico di apprendimento più
idoneo per la materia oggetto di
insegnamento quindi arredi spazi
tecnologie e quant'altro la
contraddistingue le scuole che hanno
scelto di muoversi in questa direzione
l'hanno fatto perché vogliono favorire
un tipo di didattica basata sulle
competenze un tipo didattica
laboratoriale dove mettere al centro lo
studente coinvolto direttamente nel
processo di nel proprio processo di
apprendimento in quest'altra immagine
vediamo dei ragazzi intenti in lavori di
gruppo alti intenti probabilmente a
lavorare da soli ma c'è una cosa che non
vediamo non vediamo degli studenti
seduti nei banchi file allineate
costretti ad ascoltare un docente che
parla per cinque o più ore potremmo
anche chiederci se ascoltare qualcuno
che parli sia automaticamente
significativo che vogliano somaticamente
dire che si può comprendere che si
comprende il messaggio che questa
persona vuole veicolare ma in realtà
questa domanda non ce la dobbiamo fare
in queste scuole perché qui è tutto
invertito la spiegazione si fa a casa e
la lezione si fa i compiti si fanno in
classe flip classroom classe è capovolta
il docente assegna ai ragazzi dei video
e delle risorse da fruire prima di
venire in classe al mattino per esempio
se io fossi un insegnante l'italiano
potrei assegnare il video di benigni che
spiega il canto di paolo e francesca
il tempo invece della classe al mattino
viene utilizzato in maniera diversa i
ragazzi a questo punto vengono coinvolti
in attività di dibattito si cerca di
capire se il messaggio è passato e poi
si può andare a lavorare per piccoli e
medi gruppi andando a promuovere quelle
competenze chiave tanto chiare tanto
importanti anche per
comunità europea le soft skill e
competenze critiche competenze manuali
si può mettere al centro lo studente nel
proprio percorso di apprendimento in
quest'altra scuola quest altra immagine
vediamo dei ragazzi che sono intenti a
condurre un dibattito per fare questo
cosa hanno dovuto fare ovviamente se
sono dovuti procurare delle informazioni
quindi decidono insieme con il docente
l'argomento da dibattere che può essere
un argomento di tipo trasversale o
curricolare ad esempio gli organismi
geneticamente modificati fanno bene o
fanno male i ragazzi utilizzano le
tecnologie per approvvigionarsi delle
informazioni necessarie in questo modo
fanno leva su una componente chiave
della competenza digitale come cercare
le risorse rete come saperle valutare
come attendibili una volta che si sono
fatti un'opinione torna non classe
vengono divisi in due gruppi quello che
deve dibattere a favore quello che deve
dibattere contro in questa fase ognuno
ruota ognuno fa da speaker dal relatore
tutti hanno un ruolo devono rispettare
una scaletta molto rigida di tempi e
turni di parola e alla fine la giuria
che dalla valutazione sono loro stessi
in questa maniera ragazzi apprendono a
parlare in pubblico apprendono ad
argomentare ad ascoltare il prossimo ad
essere sintetici accattivanti brillanti
in una parola imparano ad esercitare ea
maturare lo spirito critico che cos'è
questo questo l'abbiamo detto e un
orario scolastico probabilmente uno di
voi ognuno di noi si ricorderà
l'esperienza che ha fatto della scuola
superiore la secondaria di secondo grado
vedo ci sono anche diversi studenti bene
e funzionava così nelle prime ore le
materie più difficili italiano
matematica e scienze se ci andava bene
all'ultimo ora avevamo educazione fisica
ma questa parcellizzazione così
eccessiva così rigida delle discipline
spesso e volentieri non aiuta
soprattutto perché i ragazzi dalla
scuola media quando arrivano alla scuola
superiore non hanno ancora proprio
maturato un metodo di studio e quindi ci
trovavamo di fronte alla situazione di
overload cognitivo disorientamento
inoltre se noi vogliamo promuovere una
scuola che va a lavorare non sulla
trasmissione della conoscenza ma sulla
promozione di competenze cominciamo a
vedere che l'ora di 60 minuti sta
stretta non basta più allora le scuole
che hanno deciso di modificare l'orario
scolastico hanno investito proprio in
questa direzione e hanno deciso che
alcune materie si fanno solo nel primo
quadrimestre e al 3 nel secondo
alcune materie invece non vengono
proprio compattati penso ad esempio alle
lingue l'educazione motoria per ovvi
motivi
questo comporta che un docente a
disposizione il doppio delle ore per
affrontare quella materia che ovviamente
si concludono nell'arco del quadrimestre
e avendo a disposizione invece che la
mia solita ora magari tre consecutive
io come docente intanto sono incentivato
a non fare lezione frontale perché non
ce la faccia e poi ho più tempo e modo
di coinvolgere i ragazzi in attività di
gruppo in compiti autentici in attività
che li vedono direttamente protagonisti
inoltre al tempo stesso questa idea per
l'innovazione anche il vantaggio di
vedere ragazzi impegnati in numero
minore di materie in contemporanea e
quindi questo li allega dal
disorientamento cognitivo e
dell'overlord ultima immagine
in questa situazione veniamo dei ragazzi
che sono intenti a fare delle cose
strane sembra quasi che al docente sia
sfuggita di mano la situazione che in
qualche misura ragazzi possano avere
disertato la lezione in realtà quello
che sta accadendo qua è la messa in atto
di un utilizzo un po particolare del
tempo classe ovvero la lezione viene
articolato in tre momenti in tre input
dove il docente spiega la lezione ma
questi input del docente vengono ad
essere intervallati da dieci minuti di
pausa
all'interno dei quali ragazze rivolgono
altrove la loro attenzione magari
coinvolgendo se in attività manuale
comunque si distraggono
sì avete capito bene si distraggono
lo dicono le neuroscienze si ottiene il
massimo della concentrazione
quando ci si focalizza su un argomento
affrontato da prospettive molteplici
e quando si presta attenzione ai normali
fisiologici cali del picco
dell'attenzione lo sappiamo benissimo
quanto ed ex quando sappiamo che gli
speech e ha una durata limitata bene in
questa situazione
vi faccio un esempio avviene in questo
modo il docente deve spiegare il moto
dei corpi celesti
prima lo spiega nella modalità narrativa
tradizionale 15 20 minuti dieci minuti
di pausa
all'interno dei quali ragazzi si
distraggono si ritorna a lezione altri
15 20 minuti e il docente spiega il
medesimo argomento
questa volta però utilizzando dei metodi
e degli strumenti diverse quindi se
prima l'ho raccontato adesso ti faccio
vedere il moto dei corpi celesti da un
video magari di youtube o con un
contenuto 3d
magari che mi crea un'esperienza più
immersiva che approfondita terzo input e
la fase della valutazione
beh queste esperienze provengono da
alcune scuole sono soltanto alcuni degli
esempi delle scuole educativo il
progetto di cui parliamo oggi che
vengono messe al servizio della scuola
italiana
ora voi magari starete pensando sì ma
dove ci sta portando magari tra qualche
anno avremo tanti piccoli studenti
pinocchio somarelli magari con con le
orecchie da da somarello per l'appunto
oppure mi pare di vedere qualche fumetto
di qualcuno di voi che dice sì ma
insomma io me lo ricordo che andare a
scuola i miei tempi si apprendeva meglio
domande legittime
io però vi rilancio con altre domande
altre provocazioni
siamo proprio sicuri che esista un unico
modo di apprendere ea maggior ragione
siamo sicuri che quindi esista un metodo
uguale per tutti
inoltre in un'epoca in cui
l'informazione è sovrabbondante quasi
dobbiamo difenderci dall'informazione è
davvero necessario continuare a riempire
la testa dei ragazzi di nozioni ed
informazione il problema oggi casomai a
come usarla l'informazione meno sta
diventando programma di dove reperirla
il filosofo moren diceva è meglio una
testa ben fatta con la testa piena e
ancora andando avanti con le
provocazioni è possibile pensare ad una
scuola dove si va volentieri
e possibile pensare che non si debba per
forza soffrire a scuola e che comunque
si possa prendere anche con piacere ed
inoltre la dimensione delle discipline
così parcellizzate in un orario
scolastico siamo davvero sicuri che sia
in grado di restituire il senso profondo
e le trame dei saperi sono tante domande
chiaramente il dibattito potrebbe
portarci lontano
quello che è certo però che queste
scuole di cui vi sto parlando oggi del
movimento avanguardia educative insieme
un istituto di ricerca educativa per il
quale lavoro indire mettono a servizio
di tutta la scuola italiana
le loro storie di ordinaria innovazione
piccole grandi per voler provare e farsi
contagiare dal movimento come vedete
dalla cartina noi stiamo portando avanti
questo progetto da circa un anno e mezzo
in un anno e mezzo sono circa 500 le
scuole che spontaneamente hanno deciso
di aderirvi proprio con la logica del
contagio della viralità perché
l'innovazione virale avviene in una
modalità di contagio quindi avanguardia
educative così si chiama il movimento
culturale per l'innovazione che stiamo
promuovendo con il compito piuttosto
ambizioso di portare a sistema
l'innovazione in italia ma che cosa
unisce queste scuole che aderiscono ad
avanguardia educative ma sicuramente la
spontaneità la spontaneità con cui
decidono di affacciarsi in questo mondo
nuovo
certamente il coraggio la voglia di
mettersi in gioco e di cambiare la rete
il conforto di una rete in un istituto
di ricerca perché sì certamente si può
innovare da soli ma è molto più
difficile in questo caso ci sono scuole
che ti aiutano a rendere replicabile
un'esperienza di successo che loro
stessi hanno già provato la dinamicità
perché il movimento movimento che
puntino a crescita oggi abbiamo 500
scuole ma crescono continuamente e le
idee e le idee per l'innovazione che
queste crescono da idea nasce sempre una
nuova idea
la logica bottom up perché questo è un
movimento che viene dal basso
l'innovazione non può essere imposta
dall'altro l'innovazione deve venire
dalla scuola per la scuola quindi questa
è un carattere fondante di questo
movimento ed infine sicuramente una
vision una vision condivisa per il
cambiare
queste scuole di avanguardie ducati ve
hanno steso un manifesto per
l'innovazione se avete curiosità e
voglia lo trovate sul sito proprio
perché vogliono aiutare le scuole a fare
altrettanto a cambiare ma cambiare la
voglia di cambiare spesso e volentieri
non basta ci vogliono delle idee
concrete
alcune di queste velo presentate molto
rapidamente oggi il senso del movimento
è proprio questo ed è spesso in un 1 in
uno dei temi del manifesto di cui vi ho
parlato cioè promuovere l'innovazione
perché sia sostenibile e trasferibile
quindi questo il senso di avanguardia
educative e l'idea è un po questa un po
quella di di augurare alle scuole di
avere il coraggio la voglia di uscire da
quel pezzettino di zona di comfort e
affacciarsi intorno perché magari ci può
essere qualcosa di molto interessante e
divertente intorno ad affrontare quindi
avere il coraggio e la voglia di
mettersi in gioco con l'auspicio che
nessuno possa portare addosso le ferite
i segni e le ferite di quelle battaglie
che non ha combattuto grazie